auch dieses Jahr sind wir wieder im
Bundestag und bringen unsere gaben wir
sind wie die heiligen drei Könige ja
halt nur nicht heilig und nicht adelig
und wir sind zu zweit ne aber sonst wie
die heiligen drei Könige und wir kommen
nicht zu spät sondern zu früh ne ja aber
sonst wie die heiligen drei Könige jetzt
komm was für ein geiler Pulli darf man
den auch mal anfassen ja Sie dürfen
natür wissen Sie was mir da auffällt ich
GLB Markus sder trägt auch so ein
ähnlichen Po das dingus zieh das Ding a
wollen sie Weihnachtsgeschenke haben bei
ihnen bin ich nicht sicher ehrlich
gesagt weil ich nicht weiß was da kommt
die Geburt Jesu ist über 2000 Jahre ja
ich fang noch mal an aber sie wissen
schon
was die Geburt Jesu ist über 2000 Jahre
her wie war das damals wohl fragen wir
mal jemanden der live dabei war ich
glaube die Witze der heute schon waren
damals schon genauso alt aber immerhin
schön weihnachtlich habt ihr euch ja
angezogen ist ja prima da ist die Freude
groß oder ist die Freude riesig ja Frage
direkt wer nimmt dieses weihnachtenert
Schröder ich weiß nicht das gibt nicht
immer so Tiere die irgendwo die auch
alleine Weihnachten feiern kann man die
zusammenbringen das traurig wir haben
ein krippenbild was halten Sie davon
gucken Sie mal Olaf Scholz ist Jesus
Annalena berbock
maria ist dreimal Söder nur ein glaub
ichestens zweimal nicht
aus aber die Parallelen Scholz und Jesus
Baby Jesus sind doch schon da ne in
beide wurde am Anfang viel Hoffnung
gesteckt beide reden wenig und beide
haben die gleiche
Frisur also g also Frisur wir mal sie
raten ja jetzt auch dass man
Weihnachtsfeiern Absagen sollen das
machen sie doch nur damit sie nicht mit
FDP und Grünen zusammen feiern müssen
oder FDP und grünne wir sind ja sowieso
ständig zusammen da gibt's nichts zu
feiern aber ich rate auch nicht dass die
Weihnachtsfeiern ausfahren sondern mit
Maske halt mit Maske ja oder ich habe
noch folgenden Vorschlag das ist unser
Geschenk gafferape zum mundzukleben
damit endlich mal Ruhe ist in der
Koalition oh Gottes Willen das wer ich
sofort einsetzen also weiß gar nicht ob
ich mit dem bisschen hinkomme für die
Kollegen haben wir noch eine Rolle sie
dürfen sich aussuchen ob sie lieber das
Kinderbuch von rert Harbeck möchten
kleine Helden große Abenteuer ah okay
also es FST die Ampel auch sehr gut
zusammen ne bis auf Helden natürlich
sind zu wenig Bilder drin für mein Kind
das kan g dann das ist ja viel besser
das gemeinsame Buch von Christian
Lindner und Robert habbeck jetzt frisch
rausgekommen das Jahrzehnte Entscheidung
schm sie glauben wirklich wir haben ein
ganzes Buch gefälscht nein aber den
Umschlag vielleicht ich habe jetzt keine
Brille auf ne ich kann jetzt kommen hier
die Ausreden haben die voneinander
gewusst dass die da erscheinen ja wir
fragen uns das auch was glaub sie in
welchem Buch steckt mehr
Fantasie Herr Hofreiter sind sie noch da
kann nicht fassen das ist ja bizar es
ist bizar das ist wirklich bizar ne
wirklich wollen sie haben sie können
noch recycle zum Schrott Wichteln ja das
nimmt keiner nee das nimmt wirklich
keiner das stimmt dann haben wir noch
einen Gutschein für Wolfgang kubiki für
eine Karibik Kreuzfahrt aber one way
ticket Z sich diesm one way ja da
braucht man ja auch nur wenn man einmal
in die Richtung fährt wissen Sie die
erdkubel ist rund dann kommt man auch
hier wieder an haben sie mich gerade
geschlagen mit der Karte ja wir hätten
sonst ein Lottoschein ja damit die
Finanzprobleme der Ampel endgültig mal
gelöst werden ah sehr gut und die Chance
muss ich vorwen ist ein zu 140 Millionen
also immer noch wahrscheinlicher als
dass Olaf Scholz noch mal wieder gewählt
wird kann ich den auch nach der Ziehung
noch ausfüllen geht das noch sie haben
noch nie Lotto gespielt oder wir haben
lange überlegt her amtor was wir ihnen
schenken können was ist weihnachtlich
was macht ihn eine Freude und da dachten
wir einfach ach stabelgeld kenen Sie
doch bitte Leute nehmen Sie doch ja
Bundestagsabgeordnete verdienen erstens
genug zweitens geben Sie davon viel zu
viel aus auf Kosten der Steuerzahler und
deswegen müsste man sagen wenn ihr das
irgendwie sinnvoll verwenden wollt der
Bundeshaushalt könn es gebrauchen aber
die brauchen eigentlich nicht immer mehr
Geld sondern die bräuchten eigentlich
weniger Ausgaben sparen es nälich jetzt
die Devise darum muss es gehen ich
glaube das eigentliche Problem ist das
sind Hunderter wir haben natürlich auch
z für Sie bittechön wir haben einen
Gutschein für eine Mitgliedschaft im
Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht ja das weiß
ich schon wem ich den
schenke wem denn wemn sage ich ih nicht
nicht jemand den ich überhaupt nicht
leiden kann weihnachten ist ja auch das
Fest nen Liebe und die Deutschen lieben
ja den nächsten vor allem den nächsten
Kanzler das stimmt also die Menschen
lieben Olaf Scholz und also ja sie haben
einfach rechttim wieso ist es eigentlich
immer so in jedem Interview mit uns
machen Sie die besten
GS sind einfach nicht genug im Stoff
welche Figur wä denn Friedrich märz in
der Krippe oder im Stall welche Figur
der Friedrich Matz wä was ist dann der
Gottvater der der
Gottvater ja das wäre dann endgültig
Zeit dass wir alle aus der Kirche
austreten ne ich weiß nicht ob sie no in
der Kirche sind ich ja nein also
Friedrich merärz ist
ja der kommt ja vielleicht als Engel
noch mal oh ein sympathischer guter
Engel der was Gutes tut der die Dinge
verändert okay das sympathischer guter
Engel sympathischer guter Engel ja ne
der klingelt bei mir nichts bei
Friedrich MEZ doch also ich finde er ist
doch er das passt das he jetzt zieht
sich aus der Politik
zurück wer Weihnachtswunder nein nein
nein nein ich hätte noch stressbälle in
den Farben der Ampel oh welchen wollen
Sie mal richtig festdrücken ich würde
ganz gerne
Partner schon ganz gerne schreib schon
gerne den gelben dann den der löst am
meisten Stress aus bei
ih aber können mal ganz kurz zeigen okay
das ist das Gesicht bei den anderen die
sind jetzt guck aber böse und der guckt
ja vergleichweise Freund das ist passt
do zur und die FDP Set sich durch und
die anderen sind sauer das ist jetzt
ihre Interpretation können Sie noch
Friedrich Merzen Geschenk von uns
mitgeben was wollte kommt immer drauf an
weil der Überbringer der Botschaft ist
immer was soll damit geschehen Zahnarzt
oder was
so ich bin also kann Transferleistung ja
sehr gut die Schleife ist falsch grün ne
CD gegen
Transferleistung ich schenke ihnen was
echt ich schenke ihnen was zu
Weihnachten ein bisschen Zuversicht das
auch in schwierigen Zeiten das heiß es
GI neu die Dinge sich zum Positiven
entwickeln werden iche auch noch eine
Kleinigkeit könen wir vielleicht einfach
noch
mal ich komme aus dem
Sauerland von
uns könen jetzt auch
Teilen noch eine dicke
Wurst dickste Wurst von allen und er
will keine Wurst noch ein Weihnachtsgruß
an unsere Zuschauer ja nächstes Jahr
wird alles besser versprochen echt ja ja
denn
sie schmeißen einfach Dinge weg
auchun wir heben das gleich
auf das im
henus wir können einfach das Wurstwasser
trinken viel dan ja vielen lieben Dank
und froh weihnach hier so richtig
Stre der junge Wähler muss
gewonnen so im Sauerland sehr gut
seh wirlich wenachten mehr zu
Weihnachten zus mit diesen
weihnachtlichen Bildern geen wir zurück
schöner wird heute nicht mehr na doch
ich hoffe schon ja lecker oder Gottes
will danke besinnliche Zeit find
ich mal sauber machen alles
voll du l hast du denn auch ein Geschenk
für mich eigentlich h wir haben doch
gesagt wir schenken uns nichts dieses
Jahr ich dachte ja nur ah doch ich habe
dir diese schönen Videos hier
mitgebracht das ist ja genau mein
Geschmack danke ich kenne noch meinen
Fabian
super